we want to give you the answers to the
most frequently asked questions of new
farad owners hey Team Coco I am Kurt
Braunohler and these are some of my
favorite YouTube videos the first one is
mom spaghetti so some genius in the
bowels of the internet has taken Eminem
song lose yourself and then replace
almost every line with mom's spaghetti
[Music]
for deep insiders of that Eminem song he
mentions mom's spaghetti like he vomits
up mom's spaghetti and it's on his shirt
that is the one lyric that always stood
out to me when I heard the song
originally when I saw eight-mile was
that like Oh mom's spaghetti and now
it's just the whole song the precision
that this person put into editing this
is editing sound is very difficult
because there's a bunch of noise in
there inserting mom's spaghetti into
every lyric of the song it's genius
[Music]
[Applause]
birds ugh classic this is a classic if
you don't like this one
yeah town this is a seagull walking into
a shop stealing a bag of chips and then
you know thug life it's a classic meme
[Music]
it speaks to a lot of the things I like
about the world seagulls are straight-up
[ __ ] like that as everyone can agree
that seagulls are [ __ ] but here the
script gets flipped in that the seagulls
[ __ ] er II actually becomes his
greatest his greatest not flaw the
opposite of flock goddamnit what is the
opposite of flaw his greatest advantage
his greatest his greatest virtue that's
it
keep all that
[Music]
next up this is ferret fun and
fundamentals now this was put together
by my good friends Nick / Joe Pickett
from found footage festival and they
what they do is they go through thrift
stores and and estate sales and find old
VHS tapes and then cut them together to
show you the very best parts we want to
provide you with the information you
need to help you to decide if a ferret
is the right pet for you your family and
your lifestyle this is an instructional
video on how to own a ferret never leave
your ferret unsupervised with a young
child the majority of the video is about
how terrible ferrets are pets they have
scent glands on either side of the anus
which are used for protection they have
to scent glands near their anus that
they can't control where they spray it
place the ferret on your shoulder
letting it crawl around until it loses
its balance and starts to fall say no
loudly and let it fall into the
newspapers stop after the ferret has
fallen three or four times and do it
again the next day it's really beautiful
and if you get a chance go check out
found footage festival there doing God's
work they also like to steal anything
they can carry or drag and hide it boat
launches watching videos of boat
launches of large boats going from land
to water for the very first time are
like my ASMR I could watch them no [ __ ]
for hours I don't know what it is
there's a large displacement of water
there's the craftmanship there's all
these different ways of getting boats
into the water which I never knew
there's a side way where you just kind
of slide off a rail and then you tip
it's fascinating and then there's a big
wave and usually there's by standards um
by standards and they get washed away by
the wave those are always a treat so
there's a lot of elements to the boat
launch video genre that I dig of course
the weirdest part is that a lot of these
boat launch videos have 13 million views
and what a dark little weird corner of
the Internet more views than anything
I'll ever make in my entire life
alright and this is the last video we're
gonna get weird with this one as if the
boat launches wasn't weird enough
already the video is called there is no
need to be upset it's a flying lawnmower
that's a real fine
moer just flying around with an 8 head
ghosted in the lower right hand corner
and just kind of very calming music
[Music]
first off watch the whole thing I think
it's like 15 minutes it's very soothing
it's very pleasant to watch and it's
also confusing as to how the lawnmower
is flying through the air and I found
out that it is like an actual
remote-control airplane that's shaped
like a lawn mower and I guess like the
handle is the wing I don't really
understand the physics of it you can
enjoy it at any time of day night or
in-between usually I think the best time
for this would be you've had a long
night and you know I'm talking about
and you're just trying to go to bed and
you can't flip this on and just drift
off to lunacy to insane town thank you
very much for watching i'm kurt
braunohler and this was my favorite
youtube videos never give your ferret
sweets especially chocolate
[Music]